the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
as you all know game of thrones is one
of the most successful shows ever
created
it's actually one of the very few shows
that became a worldwide phenomenon
airing in over 170 different countries
it has broken numerous records for its
budget its viewership
and having the largest cast of
characters ever assembled for television
now if you're a new fan of game of
thrones then there might be some things
you don't know about the show
long before game of thrones became a
global success the show was nearly
cancelled before its first episode ever
aired
the original pilot episode for game of
thrones has almost become a legend in
itself
that first episode was so bad very few
have actually seen it
i recently made a video about that
episode where i went over some of the
things that had to be changed
the showrunners had to do a lot of
rewrites because some scenes weren't
making any sense whatsoever
they even got themselves a different
director but this isn't why i'm making
the video
some of you might not know this but
amelia clark was not the original
actress hbo had in mind for daenerys
targaryen
before amelia clarke was the mother of
dragons there was a different actress
tams and merchant standing in as the
iconic character
now some of you may be wondering why did
she leave the show
and how did she feel about her choice to
leave the show after it became a massive
success
it's been well over a decade since she
filmed that episode but for whatever
reason
she hasn't said anything about it until
now i know i was very interested in
learning what she had to say
so i figured some of you might be as
well i also want to show you what george
r martin had to say about this actress
when she first landed the job
thankfully there is still a record of
his thoughts on the internet
now keep in mind george said this over a
decade ago
before anything was ever filmed for game
of thrones
he said as daenerys targaryen we have
the lovely
and talented young british actress
tamzin merchant
i know my readers play the casting game
well confession time
so do i ever since i began a song of ice
and fire
way back in 1991 though it wasn't until
1994 that i got writing in earnest
there was always a little part of me
that would watch every television show
and movie with one eye looking for
actors and actresses who might work as
my characters
and so there i was watching the tudors
which i have very mixed feelings about i
confess
when tamz and merchant came on the
screen as the 15 year old katherine
howard
henry the ace fifth wife i set up at
once thinking hmm
she could be a good candidate for danny
katherine howard
as all students of history know ended
with her head on the block
much like henry viii's second wife anne
boylan
dany is a very difficult role she starts
out vulnerable and scared
but blooms on the dothraki sea and
becomes a leader by book's end
it's no secret that hbo's dany will
start out older than danny does in the
book
that was a change that had to be made if
we wanted to keep the sex scenes and
david and dan and i were all agreed that
the sex scenes were essential
tamsen can play much younger than her
actual age
as she does when playing catherine and
her sex scenes on the tudors were as hot
as anything i've ever seen on television
in her readings she showed danny's other
side as well
commanding and charismatic after drogo's
death i think she'll be marvelous
i believe i mentioned at worldcon that
we were down to three finalists for dany
which was true at the time
it was a hell of a hard choice since the
other two contenders were also
great so great in fact that i hope we
can use both of them and other roles
should the series last several seasons
yes i know the roles and no i won't tell
you what ones
nor the names of the other two actresses
sorry not kosher
all three of them were smashing but
tamzin was danny
well as you can see george was very
excited about
this he thought the actress would make a
great daenerys
he must have saw something in her that
reminded him of dany
it sounds like the author wanted her for
the job and i can only assume she wanted
the job
because she not only went in for the
audition but she landed the role
and even filmed scenes for the first
episode so
what happened why did she leave game of
thrones
now let's have a look at what the
actress said now that she's finally
speaking out about it
as always entertainment weekly landed
this exclusive interview
the article says the carnival row
actress and the hat maker's author
candidly discusses the great lesson of
appearing in hbo's original scrap pilot
more than a decade after playing the
mother of dragons
the then 21 year old merchant landed the
female lead role in hbo's original
ill-fated game of thrones pilot that was
filmed back in 09
the original episode was famously
scrapped and almost entirely re-shot due
to many issues
and several actors and members of the
crew were replaced along the way
one of those changes the actor who was
the mother of dragons
back then the british actress was coming
off another hit drama series
the tudors on showtime she would later
go on to join wgn salem
the cw supergirl and amazon's carnival
rowe
which is currently filming its second
season merchant
is also about to launch her literary
debut the young adult fantasy novel the
hat makers
the actress said shooting that episode
was a really great lesson
it was an affirmation about listening to
my instincts and following them because
i tried to back out of that situation
and
during the contract process i did back
out i was eventually talked back into it
then i found myself naked and afraid in
morocco
and riding a horse that was clearly much
more excited to be there than i was
marching is referring to daenerys's
wedding night which included nudity when
the exiled targaryen princess was
claimed by her brutish horselord husband
called drogo
the original version she was in was
filmed as more of a seduction
then in the eventual aired version
starring clark
one shot of the sex scene was
interrupted by the horse having an
erection
merchant also went on to say it was a
lesson that if my guts are telling me a
story isn't something i'm excited to
tell
then i shouldn't try to be excited just
because others are telling me that i
should be excited
i did not have any training as an actor
i only have my instincts
and what excites me and drives me is a
compelling story
and a compelling character so for me
game of thrones was never that
shots fired i think it's a testament to
emilia clarke for making that role
iconic
she was obviously excited to tell that
story and she was epic
and excellent but for me it wasn't in my
heart to tell it
now if you would stop the video right
here it sounds like she was the one who
walked away from the show
it sounds like she left because she did
not want to do it but that's not what
happened
usually who originally played whom
during the unaired development process
of a series being figured out is easily
forgotten
but merchant had the highly unusual
experience of watching a show where she
had a brief gig that simply didn't work
out
slowly grow into the biggest global
sensation of the 21st century
and an inescapable brand in everyday
life
she goes on to say it was kind of funny
writing to auditions on buses with
emilia clarke's face on it
like oh my mode of transport is quite
interesting today
it's been a thing i felt like i watched
unfold and it's been fantastic for the
film industry in northern ireland
and croatia and that has been really
great and fire cannot kill a dragon
one source noted that calling merchant
to inform her of the recasting decision
was the hardest phone call they ever had
to make
while hbo executive michael lombardo
said
there was a piece a casting we had to
rethink a role that was compromised we
all knew daenerys's journey was critical
her scenes with jason mamela just didn't
work while co-executive producer brian
cogman added
i thought she did a really good job it's
hard to say why things didn't work out
ultimately it's obvious amelia clark was
born to play that role
so as you can see she did not walk away
from the job on her own
she left game of thrones because she was
fired now i'll be honest
it makes me wonder if that's why she
said some of the things she did
almost like she has to convince herself
it was for the best
you will see what i mean here in a
minute marchand then added that when she
considers her opportunity on game of
thrones
she thinks of the story of the red shoes
marchand says
it tells a story of this girl who has a
pair of handmade shoes
these red shoes that she's made herself
she's walking on her path and she gets
taken by this lady in a golden carriage
the lady sweeps her off to this grand
life for riches and luxury
and she burns the red shoes that the
girl made all the girl wants is some red
shoes and she eventually buys some
and they dance her to death and for me i
think if i had to get in that golden
carriage
if i hadn't been released from my
contract i think it would have taken me
to a place far from the creative person
that i am today
also if i was very rich and famous i
wouldn't have the time to do all the
things that my soul
needs me to do expressing myself
creatively is a need that's more
important than any amount
of riches that i could have gained from
that role if i did i think i'd just
distract myself
but that's just me not anybody else i'm
very grateful to have claimed my own
path to be carving it for myself
so it sounds like she's very happy she
was fired from game of thrones because
she doesn't want to be rich and famous
at least not on the level she would have
gained if she stayed on the show
now i do agree with her to some extent
but i also disagree with her as well
i don't blame her for not wanting to be
that famous i would not enjoy getting
stopped or followed by cameras whenever
i leave my house
the millions of dollars would be nice
don't get me wrong but i also enjoy
being anonymous
or just another face in the crowd that's
one of the reasons i've never done a
face reveal
i like that i'm somewhat of an unknown
now the reason why i have an issue with
her saying this
is because she's still an actress it's
not like she walked away from the
industry altogether
she could become just as famous as
someone from game of thrones at any
moment
any one of the shows or movies she has
been in since she left game of thrones
could have made her very famous
when you're an actor you really can't
control what will thrust you into the
spotlight
now unless you're strictly filming
things that are independent or on a very
very
small budget but that's not exactly what
she's been working on either
she was on a relatively big series on
showtime and now she's on another
decently sized show on amazon
honestly if she doesn't want to be rich
or famous at all then she might want to
consider another line of work
then again maybe that's why she's
writing the book so she can leave the
big or small screen
i just think it's easy for her to say
all of this now after she was fired from
the show
but who am i to judge if that's how she
really feels then good for her seriously
i'm glad she's able to do the things
that she wants to do i'm honestly not
familiar with any of her work so i can't
even say if game of thrones was better
without her
one day i hope we're all able to get to
see that original first episode
i would really love to see all the
different changes they made i really do
think they should release it now that
the series is over
anyhow leave me some of your feedback
down below are you familiar with the
actress
and if so do you think she could have
been a better daenerys than amelia
are you glad she was let go from the
show what do you think about her
thoughts on the series now
let me know what you think as always i
want to thank all of you for watching
the video
i hope everyone has a great day i will
see you again very
soon bye
[Music]
you